i was making some predictions about
that we were going to have uh two female
candidates running
and i was wrong about half of that
and uh so i and i i think maybe i
underestimated the
um the political process that's behind
this and everything else that's been
going on
uh hey seth um and
i was uh i think i was fairly accurate
in that they did pick a woman and
uh i got run up the flagpole for as far
as the
my predictions from yes from last year
were concerned
um i got run up the flagpole by i what
the hell's her name something tracy tory
something or other i can't remember some
some chick that's uh a writer for the
for jezza jezebel yeah it's either
jezebel or huffington post i can't
remember but she was she has really
uh really come into
uh the manosphere sort of improper
and uh started like hammering on us
which was a prediction by the way that i
made back in 2019 as well
um that in the coming the next coming
years like
2019 2020 uh the mainstream was going to
take notice of of the manosphere
at warts and all and we were going to
have sort of a
pr problem i guess for lack of a better
term not that you have a pr department
or anything like that but it's just
um i think that we are convenient
with we become i think more recently a
convenient sort of foil for
for uh that element for people who are
looking for click bait
stuff like that she certainly is piled
on recently yeah oh i mean and
the reason for that is because i did a
show
i think yeah i did a show um called the
first female president which i was sort
of
reviewing my old essays about the first
female president which of course
that i wrote that essay about trump and
hillary
back in 2017 and i was sort of recapping
that for like what's going on right now
and she just jumped all up my ass for
that and said oh
he thinks that they that camel is going
to be the real
uh candidate and she's going to be the
one that's going to you know
rule the rule the country or something
like that and it's like
ever since she wrote that i i tracked
down what her
uh her twitter handle was and so every
time
something comes up like with camelot
saying oh yeah or or
or uh biden talking about how uh he's
gonna get a
a disease and and step down kind of
thing and camelot will take over
every time something comes up like that
i go and i make sure i say somebody
needs to tell this [ __ ] that this is
you know this is uh this is really
what's going on but
you know it's neither here nor there
because nobody really nobody cares no
one cares
as far as my predictions were concerned
uh i think i got half of it right at
least
i would be i will be 100 percent right
if after camelot takes office that she
appoints
or they in some way quote unquote elect
a vice a female vice president and then
that will have
completed that prediction
yeah safe around in a roundabout way um
everybody loves
laughs at canada and aha you guys have
justin trudeau
i can't wait for that to happen well you
kind of have a female president already
so
yeah he's he's pretty low on t that guy
yeah
you